[inaudible].
All right, so let's do this. I
want to do gun one on one with you.
All the things that we should know about
nuns and then I want to do the most
common misconceptions about guns because
I think part of the issue right now is
every time something happens,
every time there's a shooting,
half the people don't know
anything about guns. On one hand,
half the people then give you
all of those misconceptions.
It gets it confusing for everybody.
And even the people who I generally trust,
I sense don't know exactly
what they're saying.
So I want to do a video
with you right now.
Every time one of these incidences
happen and someone starts asking me this,
asking me that I want to go,
I've got the thing that I can point
to with the answers. So let's do gun.
What on one? What do we need to know
about guns? All right. First and foremost,
ar does not stand for assault rifle.
So when I say ar 15 that's not assault
rifle does not mean assault rifle.
And the assault rifle is a gun
that is fully automatic, right?
That means I pulled the trigger,
I hold it back and an expense,
all of the ammunition into a magazine.
So that's,
that's Jesse Ventura in Predator. Boom.
Okay, that's a great guy. Love that guy.
I can argue about, not going to say, I
wouldn't mind owning again. Um, so okay,
so that's automatic yet just hold it
down and down. It will fire every round,
uh, subsequently until it's
completely out. Okay. Right.
And does so at a very high rate of
speed. Okay. Generally speaking,
somebody automatic so that there's been
this thing where people conflate this or
use somebody automatic as a kind of a
hyperbolic way of characterizing guns as
death killing machines. Right? Virtually
every modern gun is semiautomatic.
And what that means is
one press of the sugar,
you get one bullet versus holding the
trigger down once and getting all of the
bullets. Okay. So that's a
great distinction right there.
Cause often when this happens,
you see people saying,
we have to band semiautomatics
semiautomatic. That's
virtually every month. Yeah.
He's just so it's not because all that,
the only difference between that and uh,
what I guess it's fully automatic stuff.
Well,
what's one that you're just loading
one bullet in the that. Okay.
So that would be a bolt action,
right?
So there's fully automatic semi
automatic and bolt actions, right?
Bolt action more. Uh, it was more
aligned to like, like hunting, right,
or high purpose,
high precision shooting.
And it's a bolt because it allows you
to build the gun up in such a way where
you [inaudible] at the tighter constraints
within a gun and it allows you to be
more accurate without certain mechanism
moving back and forth, causing,
throwing off the accuracy of the shot.
So you would say then that when,
when all of these people come out and
say we have to ban semiautomatics,
that they are actually just flat out
confused or intentionally conflating or a
obfuscating what the truth is
related to them? Yes, absolutely.
And so it's either they're ignorant or
they're doing a purpose for like you just
stated. Okay. So what is the, so
let's do some NRA stuff while we're,
while we're doing this,
what does the NRA stance on automatics
just being able to hold and, and shoot.
I mean the, it's currently
regulated is the way it stands.
Like right now there's this like
in order to get an automatic gun,
there's a certain process you have to
go through in order to get them and that
and that. It's been that way
for a very long time now.
And that's been that it
exists as it does now. Um,
and that's essentially war where the
stance is that fully automatic guns,
what are people using fully
automatic guns for? So, um,
cause I think this is where
you'll hear people go,
well no one needs an automatic to huh.
We'll see. Here's the thing though,
it's the idea of putting it under
the guise of a needing, right,
their name another right. Where we
use that same standard, you know,
begs the question. It's
so it's like, okay,
you haven't fully automatic gun and you
have semiautomatic gun shot, bolt action.
There are different reasons why
you would want each of these guns.
Now I can delve into that.
But then that starts getting into the
very nerdy side of firearm ownership where
they're enthusiasts aspect
of that comes into it.
It's understanding tactically why you
would want certain things. And so for me,
I'm not personally, I don't have a problem
with people on a fully automatic gun.
Personally.
I,
I just don't see that as a significant
danger above and beyond say owning a
nuclear suitcase.
Right?
So if people tried to make that absurd
argument to me before, it's like,
well then walled true real other than,
well that's because there's a,
there's a cost benefit ratio that
doesn't make any sense, right? The,
that you just, that's inherently
self destruction. So how was,
how is that protecting you in any way
from the very thing that you're supposed
to be taking yourself against?
Do you think there should be a higher
threshold to be able to get an automatic
than some of the other records
you're talking about? Me Personally?
Threshold in what respect? Like in terms
of either hire back, graded background,
Chang's or references.
So let's,
so let's talk about background
checks for a minute.
So there's this identity
[inaudible] notion that we
don't have background checks
for guns. We do. And the funny
thing is we in the gun community,
because I've become a
victim of technology,
and what I mean by that is people think
that just because I can go into a guns
if I really wanted to, I can go on gun
store right now by gun within two minutes.
Just like that. You can, yeah,
because you've done all of
the background stuff. See,
that's the thing though. I'm still going
under. I'm undergoing the same processes.
So I go into a store, I find
the gun, I like this gun.
I said I want to buy this gun.
I fill out the 40 four's a form 44 73
which asked me a series of questions.
Then they take that information and they
submit it to the FBI database and they
do a background check. But it
happens instantly because technology,
right people,
it's interesting because there's a lot
of people who feel like I should undergo
some type of CIA investigation
before I buy a gun.
The same people who also hate the
government. Exactly. Right. So when they,
the instant aspect of the background
check causes people who don't know very
much about the process to think
that there isn't one. Right.
Just because I can buy the gun easily
doesn't mean it was done thoroughly.
You know what I'm saying?
I underwent the background check.
There's a system there,
they checked it against the system.
I don't have any felonies or anything
that prevents me from owning a firearm.
I'm allowed to buy the gun. Okay.
So when people say there are,
there are no background checks are
background checks aren't tight enough or
however you want to extrapolate that,
is there any credence to any of that
that that you can, so now let's talk.
So I think what you're,
what you're kind of going into is the
universal background checks, right?
So when they say universal back now
they do conflate these terminologies.
There's universal background check
is a very specific statement.
It's not like saying coke,
right?
Cause people here universal
background checks on all the,
here's the background check part.
That universal means something.
And what that means is it's a requirement
that on every single transaction you
have to undergo a background check,
even private transactions. Right?
So right now in California,
if I had a gun, right,
I can bring a gun into California. Just
can't carry it. But you were like, hey,
you know what kinds I liked
that gun you have, right?
I want to buy from you in California.
I can't sell it to you right
now. What? Here's what I can
do. I can say, all right,
cool.
When I get back to Texas,
I'll transfer the gun to a
gun store here in California,
if it's on the specific list that allows
you to actually own that gun. Right?
Cause Cause California has a
designated or exactly I stuff. Yeah.
And then you would have to go to the
gun store and then buy it right now
let's say I decided to
give you the gun anyway,
privately right now in this room.
No one else is here.
But you went on and I saw the, the gun.
Let me shut the cameras, Huh? Yeah. Yeah.
I don't have any plans on going to
jail. But, and I sell you the gun,
you and then let's say you have the gun,
what is there to check against what
databases that are check against to
determine whether or not you got a
background check for that gun now just
completed two issues right now. Yeah,
so, well if we did it on the DL there,
there's no,
there's no way.
And that's what the whole concept of
the universal background check is.
It is to require a background check
for every private transaction. Now,
legally,
right now I can't do it,
but like in Texas I can sell a gun to a
friend and as long as I know he's not a
prohibited person and I know he's
not a felon, I can sell him that gun.
No problems.
That's completely illegal.
What the universal background check
idea s suggested I should have,
I should be required to
undergo a background check
before I can sell in that gun.
And that would mean you,
he and I would have to go to a gun
store and undergo a background check.
Then he can go and buy the gun from me.
So is the problem with the way it is,
Carly say in Texas,
the way you're describing that you
just would not know potentially enough
information about the person you were
selling it to? Yes. That's a potential.
Absolutely.
And so the reason why I'm against the
universal background check is because
there is no other way to enforce it.
But for a national gun registry,
because otherwise you have nothing
to check it against. Right.
To say if a cop walks on the street
and you have a gun, he was like,
do you get a background
check for that gun? Yeah.
How's it going to prove otherwise?
Unless there's a national registry
and then as I was, okay, fine,
well then let's have a national registry.
No,
because we've seen time and time again
that when the governments have a national
registry for firearms, they
subsequently use it to confiscate guns.
Now the problem is when you say that
they try to put the tin foil hat on you,
right. Except because what
they, what they envision is,
you know,
roaring truck,
black military trucks coming down the
street pulling guns from people's houses.
No, that's not what happens or how
they do it. It's a constructive.
And then when you have potential
presidential candidates
like Hillary Clinton's
suggesting we should take apart,
we should take up the Australia model,
which did that very thing.
They use the national,
they use a national gun registration
to tell people to say, you know what,
you need to turn in your guns.
It's a voluntary buyback. No,
it's an NGO. It's a, it's a
mandatory buyback. Right. So,
and if you don't sell your guns
back, guess what? You go to jail.
That's a confiscation. Yeah,
it's a constructive confiscation,
but a compensation nonetheless.
Just because they didn't roll the military
trucks down the street and pull them
out of your house doesn't mean it isn't
confiscation. And so that's why I'm,
I'm adamantly against
universal background checks.
Unless you can demonstrate away from me
for it to be applied in such a way that
would now require gun registry.
Because I do not trust my government
not to exploit that registry in their
favor. Yeah. So how much of this
then, cause we've talked about it,
you said to me right before we started,
you're sort of a libertarian I
think is exactly what he said.
I don't want to put words in your mouth.
How much of this does go back to that
states should be able to make the
decisions that they see fit.
I mean I suspect you probably wouldn't
be that thrilled living in California.
So that's in the weather. I, I'm here in
California. Whether the women the food.
Yeah. But yeah, it's pretty good
food in Texas. Yeah, we do. Yeah.
I'm not complaining about that. Um,
so see that's just it too. It's like,
well how far those stay towards go from
the standpoint of violating my second
amendment. Right. Right. I believe in
states' right. Try them to a point.
You start violating my
constitutional ones.
And so when you have places
like California, which I think,
I think I'm being currently violated now,
the fact that I can't carry my gun,
what is the difference I can take?
I can take my car with my Texas license
and drive it right into California.
No one has a problem with that.
I can drive up and down these
roads and as fast as I want,
as recklessly as I want. Yeah. That
might be illegal, but I still do it.
Does that potentially do it?
But yet I can't carry the thing that I
carry to protect my life with the same
license.
That doesn't make no sense to me like I
am I any in any less danger here than I
would be in Texas. If anything, I can
make the argument that I'm more, I,
there's more danger from me here in
that I don't know the area very well.
So in a weird way, you're actually making
a non states' rights argument here,
right? Because if you're saying you
want the same thing everywhere, that's,
that's not a states' rights argument.
It's not that. But that's what I'm saying.
Yeah.
Because,
but that's under guise of meat feeling
like me not being able to carry as a
violation of my constitutional
right. Right. Because states rights,
it doesn't allow them to violate those
constitutional rights. And that's,
that's the argument I'm making now.
It's difficult because then
you start talking about the
idea of having a uniform,
like concealed carry platform, right? Um,
where one license allows you to
carry a gun everywhere, right?
Then you start getting into the weeds of,
okay,
well that's violating state's rights,
but that's only if you don't see my
ability to carry a firearm as a, as a, um,
sorry,
uh,
my ability to carry a firearm as a
violation of my constitutional rights.
It's an interesting philosophical
place to talk because it's like,
it just depends where you start.
Yeah.
Because even though I'm definitely
a states' rights guy, I,
I hear what you say there. And then on
the other hand, as a state's rights guy,
to me,
if a state wants to have stricter
laws and you are a big gun guy,
then you actually are allowed to leave.
It's kind of it as,
I would say for virtually every
other situation, it's kind of shitty.
It doesn't feel great to have to
leave a place that you want to be at.
But if they're doing things as part of
their state experiment that you don't
like, well it's on, it's on you
to get gold. Yeah. But if that,
if that same state creates a law that
violates my right to privacy, right.
Well we have constitutional rights that
supersede. So I get, I get the trailer.
Are we missing anything
else on the technical front?
Cause we did that pretty calm,
uh,
from a mechanical standpoint just for
them and the mechanical standpoint or,
or just any of the language that we use
related to this. Okay. Okay. So yeah.
So then of course there's some
people can say it's trivial,
some people say it's not. So the
magazine versus clip, it's general terms.
It's actually, it's called a
magazine, a clip as an actual thing.
It's just different from a magazine that,
that that's kind of slightly trivial,
but it does typically kind of exposed
people who don't really know much about
guns.
When you say clip versus magazine,
cause the proper terminology
would be magazine. Um,
as far as any other mechanical components,
well,
what do I need to know about the magazine
though? Well, that's just terminology.
This is semantics,
right?
I don't always go about correcting people
because I feel like it just creates it.
It kind of makes me look
like an ass to a degree,
but that's why we're doing this.
I want to clean up.
The biggest thing is just the
assault weapon thing, right?
Because the Ar 15 is this
a villian weapon? It's,
it's designated as the biggest difference
between an ar 15 and an assault rifle
is that the assault rifles,
fully automatic and they are 15 isn't,
that's the biggest distinction
between the two. Now of course,
then you could make the argument,
well that's some very minor distinction.
You know, there's a lot of
people who make that argument,
but I don't look at the Ar
15 any differently than I
look at the handgun in that
sense.
So every time when one of these happens
and we hear the Ar 15 is a weapon of war
and Solo handguns,
you would basically put their 15 in
the handgun in the same category. Yes.
As pulling ones. Yeah. She
even once, yeah. So that
would not be categorized as a,
as a weapon of war. We'll see
that steam, that estimation,
that terminology is designed to,
to manipulate the emotions of people
who don't know anything about guns.
So when you hear, if you don't know
anything about firearms and you here,
he used a weapon of war, technically
speaking all guns or weapons before,
right? So words can be weapons
of war. Exactly. Yeah. So,
but what that does mentally,
like they understand language
very well and I tell you, they,
they liked turned like 90 human.
But
in terms of the,
I call it the anti gun side of it,
of things they understand the use
of language very well. And um,
and they confuse it purposely.
So when you hear someone who doesn't
know anything about firearms,
think about it.
Like if,
if I'm already kind of how I'm a little
scared of firearms and enter here,
he used a weapon of war.
What image comes up in your mind?
It's, it's Rambo, you
know, just running down.
They're just going crazy and
that's exactly what he's doing.
He could do the same thing with
the handgun. And so the, the,
the biggest thing that I like to,
when I'm having these conversations with
people, you're going to walk away with,
we gonna walk away with two with two
points of two trains of thoughts.
I'm either going to get you to admit
you just want to ban all guns or you can
see my perspective because if you're,
if you're willing to say, you know what,
we need to get rid of all
this salt weapons as they,
as they understand them to be,
which is essentially ar fifteens but now
it's actually become even more broader.
Like we to get rid of all
semiautomatic weapons, right?
That's virtually every modern gun.
So let's say that they want a band aid
off fifteens air 15th rifles aren't even
used. Like the, the,
the percentage that rifles are used in
actual shootings is so low and marginal.
It's, it's unreal. So then why
are we focusing on that? But okay,
so then what are emotions
are hand guns. Yeah. Right?
So if you get rid of that,
and we got rid of Ar 15 and then we have
another shooting happened because the
are most deadliest school mass shooting
was Virginia Tech and he used the hangar.
So then what happens
if that happens again?
So now what are you going to
ban you in the band handgun?
And that's when you're stuck having
to confront the fact that okay,
either you really just want to ban
all guns or you understand that the
distinction is irrelevant,
right?
With God to get to the absolute point of
issue in why these things are happening
and focusing on gun is doing a
disservice to the conversation.
It sounds like I'm just utilizing,
I'm using the bigger issue as a scapegoat,
but in reality, if you really sit
down and think about it, right?
We have over 300 close to 400 million
guns in this country and not going
anywhere and understanding that you've
got to then sit down and say to yourself,
all right,
if we're going to try to fix this issue
of gun violence or just violence in
general, we've got to get to the root
of issue of why people are doing it.
And then understanding that staying
within the context of reality,
we've got to understand
well in the process,
I still have to protect myself and
because people are still stupid,
still gonna be able to get their
hands on guns, whether illegal or not,
and and use them to commit crimes
in the Brighton people's lives.
I've got to be put in a
situation to defend against
that so you can bend all the
Ar 15 what does it mean?
It's going to stop somebody from getting
one on a black market. So now, yes,
I don't run from the fact that the ar
15 is a more powerful platform that I
agree with and I don't think I,
I don't run from that.
They're going to be people on there who
are going to be mad at me for saying
that.
But the reason why it'll rough on me
just because that's the very reason why I
want an ar 15 when it
comes to defending my life.
I don't want it to be a fair fight.
Hmm.
Period.
I don't want to have to confront someone
with an ar 15 with a hand gun if I
don't have to. If you come in my
house, I'm not grabbing a handgun.
I'm grabbing in the office.
Okay, let's see. We have this strange
thing. It's like when people will say,
I'm okay.
Well the,
the Second Amendment says the right
to bear arms and then they'll put up a
picture of, you know, the type of
arms that existed way back when and,
and it's like, well then we
should be have the right to that.
Cause that's what they
were talking about it.
It's like this is so
disingenuine very disingenuous.
It's like they were also talking about
why you should be able to form a militia.
And it's like the thing that we'd be
fighting against now has a lot more power.
And it doesn't mean that just
cause you have some guns,
you're gonna be able to stop the guys
in the black trucks as you talked about
earlier. But maybe you could defend
yourself a little bit longer.
And who knows what happens
with a little bit of time.
I mean fruit and be real with it.
They're still fighting in Afghanistan
and those guys over there just use an AK
47 huh?
You get what I'm saying?
So like we can't just because we're
going to lose anything that you just lie
down and do it, you know?
And the whole notion of like,
um, ah man, I just lost
the train of thought.
This idea of owning firearms
to combat the government.
It's in and they think it's preposterous.
But I'm like,
ask the people in Venezuela
what's going on? And again,
these are now the people,
at least in this current moment,
people who say that the government is
run by Orange Hitler. Exactly, man.
It's it really well. Well this is a
good spot to I think change to mind.
And as I said to you before we sat down,
I've never considered myself a gun
person per se. Uh, I'm interested in,
I'm always interested in
talking about these things,
but I do find myself now more pro gun.
It's probably not even the
right phrase to say, yeah,
then I've ever been in my life and I,
but that had for me,
it has more to do with that.
I really understanding what rights are
in a much clearer way and what I want the
government to do and not do. And
once you understand that, then
you know, it's tough. It's tough
to take other positions. It is.
So is there anything to you that when
they always say sensible gun control and
I'll always see the pro gun,
people will say,
well the people that always say that just
don't know what they're talking about.
And I sense you're probably in that spot
cause that you were just saying what
they do with language.
Yeah.
So sensible gun control.
Most of the time when people say that
they actually advocate things we already
have. So bad background checks,
things of that nature. Right.
And then you like, and you
have other language like the,
the loop, uh, the gun show,
the gun, the gun show loophole.
Yeah, let's talk about
that. That's not a loophole.
All the, all that is, is a private
transaction. That's all that is.
And it's just happening, happening and
just so happened to happen at a gun show.
If you bought a gun from an
actual dealer at a gun show,
you still have to undergo
a background check. So the,
when they say loophole with a loose
saying is that if you are at a gun show,
you're not a dealer, you can actually
sell that gun at the, if you are,
if one the person's not a prohibited
possessor, you are from the same state,
then yes. If they, if there's nothing
that precludes them from owning a firearm,
legally I can sell them a
gun at a gun show. Right.
So the only slippery part of that
is what we talked about earlier,
which is you just may not know all the
information. Exactly. Cause there is a,
there is, I guess there's a little
bit of a gray area and that one,
is that a fair in terms of the yeah,
that you're sort of taking
somebody's word for it at that point.
[inaudible] meets somebody that day and
they're like, I want to buy that gun.
And you say to them, you ask them
all the appropriate questions,
they could be lying to you.
Absolutely. But that's just, yeah.
But then that sold in the way the
response that they have to that is the
universal background check. But
as I pointed out, how do you,
how do you enforce it
without a national registry?
And then with that national registry,
even with the national registry,
it doesn't stop anything.
Right? We, we, we,
we tend to go down this
road of just wanting to do
things to make ourselves feel
better.
But in reality,
namely one mass shooting that would've
been prevented with the universal
background check.
Now one,
because even the people who had gone
to aren't supposed to have them,
they got them illegally.
Right.
It wasn't because there wasn't a universal
background check that stopped him
from getting it. No, it wasn't. So I
have to, I have to ask the question,
I go then why are we doing this other
than just to make ourselves feel better
cause it's literally doing nothing.
Nothing.
And so that's why like the person who
who bought and sold a gun privately at a,
at a gun show could have done that
in the parking lot of the gun show,
could have done it at their house
before going to the gun show.
You get what I'm saying?
But what it does is when you frame
it within the context of the gun show
loophole,
it makes it seem like it's this bizarre
where everyone comes there together and
sells illegal guns. Right, right. That's
the image that's created in the mind.
Like it's barter town.
Exactly. Like they feed on,
they feed on the ignorance of people.
Right. Because like they're not,
everybody knows that much about guns.
It's like, it's one of those things,
it's like,
I don't know.
I don't know a lot about a lot of other
things that people may know a lot about.
Right.
So if you tell me something and I'm not
really researched and schooled on that
issue, you can give me the beliefs
from pretty kooky stuff. Yeah.
And that's what I'm talking to you.
I mean,
that's what you consistently see every
time we talk about this and you know,
there's this other piece of it where
it's like every time a shooting happens,
you know, there's this pile on where it
would not now we should talk about it.
Yeah.
And then there's this other part of us
where it's because we go from one crisis
to another. Yeah. That there's never
re, it seems to me at this point,
we never really have time to really
ever fully unpack any of these things.
I think. I think there's moments like
this, but on a national level, we're,
we're not particularly good at these
conversations because then what it does is
just turns into a political
sparring match. Yeah.
I mean right after the last
shooting and when, when, uh,
Dana Lotion and Rubio are on that CNN
town hall. I mean it was made them,
I mean the gladiatorial fest,
it was a disaster.
I mean it was everything
I hate about cable news.
It was everything I hate about just
the quick bites and of all of this and
flashiness and just who can we take out
right now? It was a disaster. And then,
and I sat in,
I pointed this out,
how can we have a real honest conversation
when they try to paint program people
as crazy when we say no,
the ultimate goal is to band dones.
But then I can watch CNN live town hall
where we will suggest you do realize
banding all somebody automatic guns is
essentially banning all guns and the
entire stadium erupts in
applause and cheers. Yeah.
So then it goes,
Yo Rubio said exactly what you said.
He may started cheering even even when
confronted with the core because Rubio
said, look, you want to bet on
somebody might have guns here,
let me educate you really quickly
and tell you that virtually all guns.
So even when he corrected them so
it wasn't, they can't, they can't,
they can't claim they were ignorant on
it cause he just explained to them that
means manning virtually
all guns and they rocked it
so it goes, okay, so now you
have all those programs are like,
we just going to go back to our clients.
There's no discussion because while,
while we're trying to be fair, you're
ultimate goal is to try to ban them all.
Yeah.
There was that moment.
I'm sure you remember this after the
Parkland shooting when they had the big
rally and one of the survivors got up
there and said, we're going to come.
What was the line?
Do you remember the exact line where she
said basically we're going to come for
the semiautomatics now,
but we're going to come for
everything later or something.
Something to that effect. I'm slightly
butcher, but I thought, wow, now,
now you're flat out saying
and you're just giving,
you're telling them now. So
I could see why. You know, I,
I see this with all my frustrations
with the left all the time.
It's like I know they're never gonna stop.
I've seen it so consistently and that's
why I'm staking out some positions.
But sometimes it's, it's kind of
sucky to have to just be like,
well the people that I'm fighting against,
so to speak,
they're not dealing in the same
world that I'm dealing in. And I,
and that makes it more important
for me to stake out a position.
But the thing that's most frustrating
about it is the way they'll color it in
the mainstream media is
that were unreasonable. We
don't want to move on inch.
We've dug her heels in. All we want
is we don't care about anything.
And really what it is is no,
I let you into my house and now you're
trying to take my house from me.
So get out. Cause that's essentially
what they're saying is all right.
So they'll say, well, common sense.
That's why we hate that word common
sense because it cause it's disingenuous.
It's like, well we need common sense
measures after a shooting. All right,
then another shooting happens.
We need more common sense measures
in another shooting happened.
We need even more common sense measures.
Windows common sense measures stopped
being common sense and just intruding on
my rights and I can see the, you know,
you know my thing for guns to use,
free speech to me and it's like
I can see this coming with that.
If these guys took control,
you'd start seeing,
well we can have free speech but we
need some common sense controls around
actually. So I, so I do understand that
position. Like I tell people all the time,
I'm like, there are over 300
federal gun laws in this country.
I think we've been reasonable.
I think we were really
truly being unreasonable.
We wouldn't have over 300 federal gun
laws and I can't begin to tell you how
many we have on a state level,
right?
So it's incredibly disingenuous to
think that we're just being hard,
hard assets who don't want to
move one inch on the issue. Right?
No one's saying it
should be a free for all,
where we're just handing out guns
to everyone like Oprah, right?
I don't think anybody has a problem
inherently with background checks.
Now we start talking about
universal background checks.
That's a different thing.
But since nobody, since they never
want to make that distinction, right?
No one ever knows that you can't, you
can't. Exactly. And then the idea of like,
you know, we can talk about
gun free zones, right?
And it begs the questions
like what does that,
what does that sticker on when
they're going to do for me?
So now I have to make like people don't
really like to sympathize with gun
owners in a sense of like, we
all want the same result, right?
We want the killing the stock.
We want the violence to stop.
Notice I said violence and killing,
not just gun violence. Right?
Because we can't just focus on gun
violence because violence is violence.
However you die, you die and
it's bad. All the way around.
But when I have to make a decision about
whether or not I potentially break a
law to go into an establishment that may
or may not cause me to need my gun at
some point, man, that's messed up.
And I know that there are a lot of people
who don't see it that way because they
don't see value in the second amendment
because they're not firearm owners.
Right?
There are a lot of people who look at
the second amendment is useless because
they don't own firearms.
But when you have a group of people who
understand the importance of it and how
it fits into their lives, and they
understand that at the end of the day,
when something happens, the only person
who's gonna be there to stop it is you.
That's a big deal.
So it's not just me trying to protect
a piece of metal because I just want to
have fun with my guns. No,
it's much bigger than that.
It's this idea that I have to rely on
myself. You can tell me all day long,
police are going to be there,
the police are going to be there,
but they're not going to be,
they're just not.
And then you can you name or at Parkland.
Exactly right.
So then you can you add kids,
family into the mix that ratchets it
up to a whole nother level. So that,
what about the piece of this that
just sort of optics. So you know,
every now and again you'll see a picture
of like three dudes with big ass guns
at Aaa. You know, like an open car. Now I
know if I was, if I walked into Napoleon,
three guys came in with big ass guns
on their back. Yeah. Pro Notice.
Well I would take notes and I
probably leave. I probably would,
I would just be like, you
know, and again, I'm here,
I'm here in California where that
would be so, so out of the norm.
But for the person that's living in Texas,
right, you can do this. If I was in AAA,
right, and it's three guys walking
in, I probably would leave no one.
Everything that you just said there,
knowing that these guys are probably
NRA members and and as far as I know,
no NRA member has ever done a a mass
shooting. Right. Okay. So you know,
cause you see this all the time,
these celebrities, Michael,
Ian Black like that on the show who's on
this rampage telling everyone that you
guys are terrorists.
I mean really that you're,
you're part of a terrorist organization
and saw all the other 5 million members.
But I think there is certainly
about some of the optics of that.
You know what I mean? Like I would be
nervous now. I get your point would be,
well those guys are going to protect you
when the other guy walks in or whatever.
Then some of that may be feelings
over facts right there, but it just,
it just is the interesting thing about
it that is a big debate within the gun,
the gun community as a whole. The idea
of open carry versus concealed carry.
I don't ever open carry except for maybe
if I'm out hunting or I'm on the range
or something like that. But
that's, that's a personal decision.
I'm choosing my own for various
reasons. One, sometimes I, I,
I'd rather not have the attention.
And tactically I liked the advantage
of having the element of surprise.
You don't know I have a gun on me,
so if I had to use it,
I'm going to be reacting. Right? I'm
not going into a place to shoot it up.
If somebody decides to come into
a place where she could about,
I'm going to be reacting to that.
So I need all the advantages I
get from my personal perspective.
So I want the element of surprise.
There are some people who
think only alternative,
they feel like just the mere presence of
that gun is a deterrent from anyone who
wants to come in and do some bad.
So for guys casing out a couple of
stores and then he sees there are certain
citizens in there with long guns and
some that have a hand guns on the side of
your hip, then that's
a deterrent. Right? Um,
I understand the alarm that people who
don't necessarily engage in interact with
fire arms get when they see people walking
around with rifles. Right. Even I've,
I've,
I've ever been,
I've seen a couple of people in Texas
do it and initially my gut reaction and
I'll admit was like what's going on here?
Um,
now I'm very versed firearms
and I have a gun too.
So at that point I
actually almost welcome it.
And the reason why is because
if you're going to do something,
I now get to see you attempt to do it.
You get what I'm saying?
It does a telegraph. They were in
a unique case on this one. Yes.
But I'm speaking from purely a place,
a personal preference, right? Yeah.
And not to be getting on the whole
for anyone else or anything like that.
Me Personally, I would rather like to
know you have it right. If I can see it,
cause then I know where to
focus my attention versus
me kind of being alone to a
state of complacency
because of its absence.
And then all of a sudden somebody stands
up and decides he wants to shoot the
place up and then I have to react to that.
Um, but again, that's tactics, right?
That, that's just personal
preference in that regard. However,
I do understand the alarm that somebody
who would have seen you three guys
walking into AAA with the, with
rifles, because it seems seemingly,
especially to them, they seems like that's
a bit excessive. I'm, I allowed to you.
If I can conceal carry a rifle,
I would because it's better at defending
me than a handgun was the only reason.
The only reason I have a handgun,
it was because of small
enough for me to conceal.
It allows me to live my
life in an uninterrupted,
otherwise I'd walk around with a rifle.
Okay.
So we can't end without doing sort of
what I think would be the big question for
everything we've talked about here.
And for someone that works with the NRA
and your show is on NRA TV and all that.
So what is going on in America right now
that seems to be unique to our society?
We do have more shootings here than I,
and I think virtually all other
western nations combined. Um,
so, okay. I forget to fact check me on
that if I that one. But it does seem it's,
and even if I'm slightly, oh no,
no, you're good. You're good.
It seems that there is something uniquely
happening here now I would argue then
there's all sorts of mental health issues
and probably a prescription drugs and
maybe nonprescription drugs
and all sorts of other stuff.
So there's a couple of things.
So I'll try to,
I'll try to keep this as concise as
possible because we are going to get into
weeds for a split second here. So first
of all, let's talk about mass shootings,
right? Our school school,
Mexican silver instance.
I recently just read a study
from Northwestern university,
I'm not too long ago,
which talked about comparing the number
of school shootings back in the 90s
versus the versus today.
And what they concluded essentially was
the perception is that it's happening
more frequently,
but it's not,
it's actually on par or even
less now than it was then.
Now you can, people who are
going to seem like, oh my God,
how could you possibly say that? Google
it. It's a Northwestern university, uh,
research. Uh, I can't remember the
actual title of their actual research,
but we're going to grab it from you
after this and [inaudible] link to it.
And absolutely.
So that being said,
mass shootings account for a very,
very,
very marginal percentage of
shootings in this country.
Let's start off with the overall.
So 35,
35 to 36,000 people each
year die from guns, right?
I didn't specify gun violence, but
just guns. Cause they don't do that.
They'll just say gun violence.
Right?
So 60 about 60 to 65% of those,
that 35,000 as suicides.
Now when I'm not saying is we don't
care about suicides. We do. However,
when it comes to the idea and the issue
of somebody shooting at me, that's a,
that's not, it's not Jermaine.
Yeah. But then even still,
if you want to make the argument,
well, if we had less guns,
we'd have less suicides.
That's also not true because our suicide
rate is on par with every other major
country. So if it was a case
that the more guns you have,
the more suicides we'd be
leading the charge. We don't
they where there's a will,
there's a way. Exactly.
Right. Even tomorrow,
the more more famous suicides we've had,
they didn't use guns.
So we sat there number side,
which is a huge number,
65% it's huge number out of 35 36,000 so
then you have about one to 3% which are
justifiable homicides.
That self defense,
that's including police shooting
criminals who are shooting at them. Right?
And people who use guns in self defense.
Right.
You've got to set that aside because
that's not the issue we're trying to
address.
So set that number side and then you
have about 5% which are accidental.
Right? Kid gets fined to gun
pull triggers. Unfortunate.
Extremely unfortunate.
However,
I believe personally half of that can
easily be addressed with more education.
So if we took the energy
that we took that we placed,
now I'm trying to vilified guns and
have national campaigns teaching people
about gun safety,
that we'll cut that number in half
because a lot of these accidents easily
preventable. But they're just people
who have come to just don't know.
And so if we spent time
educating those people,
do we know what percentage of that
subset is getting those guns legally or
illegally? Cause I would imagine
that a lot of it's probably illegal,
which is why they don't know
how to use the gun in the first.
I'm not going to assume I have that answer
because I don't have that hard number.
Um, but, and I would, I'm, I do feel
comfortable assuming that as well. Right.
Um, and so if we take that, the
accidents to set that aside,
purely homicides,
we're looking at around
seven to 10,000 every year.
Right now that's a different
looking number, right.
When will be accounted for the,
all of the, the con, the con,
the context here with those,
those other shootings. Now,
the vast majority,
I'd say close to 80% that I've read in
a couple of articles of those homicides
are happening in the inner
cities of our country.
All right? So then reason goes. All right,
so let's look at those inner cities and
let's look at the dynamics there, right?
You have low jobs, lack of
economic opportunity, um,
destroyed households and a narco economy
that warrants that warrants but creates
the necessity for this type of violence.
So if we dealt with the socioeconomic
aspects of what's going on in those areas
too, we really have a gun problem, okay?
Just think about it. I know, I know other
communities filled with black people,
they have guns, they don't have
the same level of violence.
Cause I only say black people because
most people associate the inner city with,
with black people,
right?
But the reason why we had that high
level of concentration of violence,
it's because of the conditions
in those environments.
And then even within those communities,
there are tough.
The vast majority of people in
those committees are good people.
And it's a very minor group of people
who are creating a large number of the
violence, right? So there's
something to be said,
do we really have a gun problem or do we
have a socioeconomic suicide problem in
this country?
Because at the end of the day,
there's 35 to 36,000 that people
assuming is all gun violence by way of
homicides, people shooting at other
people to kill them. It's not the case.
We're looking at closer to
the seven to 10,000 if that.
And so if you take those numbers and
you comparing them other countries,
then how does it look
to be continued? Yeah. Well,
I'm so glad that we finally did this
and we will definitely do this again
because I absolutely,
this story and everything we've talked
about here is just going to continue.
I mean,
these are the battles that we're now
fighting on many fronts related to the
constitution and free speech and
free expression and your ability to,
to own your life and all that stuff. And
that's all we ask is that this is this,
let me and
well, I'll say one last thing. Yeah.
There are a lot of people who was like,
why do you feel the need to carry a gun?
Why?
Like like the chances of you needing to
use that gun to protect yourself 1% and
the answer I have for that is this,
you may be right.
Sansomeana need to care to actually
use my gun to defend myself.
Maybe really slim,
maybe 1% but if that 1% happens,
it's 100% of everything.
The consequences are 100% and
that's why it's so important.
Yeah.
All right,
well that's how you, and to show you, you
know, you, maybe we'll do this next time.
Maybe we'll bring you on with someone on
some of the absolute side of the issues
on this and we'll tell him we'll have
that conversation. Sounds like a plan.
All right. For more on calling on check
them out on Twitter. Mr. Cole? No.
R.